à l'école jusqu'à 8 ans je me faisais
appeler michael o ma mère faisait sa
maison
mère quand elle était petite ses frappes
et éric lopez jusqu'à
la mairie courait jusqu'à c'est quand
même 12 13 ans quand la mer se fait
appeler comme un homme eric lopez
et on perd ça faisait appeler martin
c'est de comprendre et ça croyez que
c'est vrai mais les marckois chevaux et
mr delajoux
père est un ancien septième ciel yeomans
non mais par contre je crois que c'est
johnathan tu crois pas mais pas
seulement après
le début des imams et bien lourd
absolument c'est geoff johns j'arrivais
johnatan jonathan alors on n'a pas à des
stray non voilà ce qu'elle a dit quand
j'étais petite je rêvais d'être un
garçon à l'école jusqu'à 8 ans je me
faisais appeler michael jay dans les
vestiaires des garçons j'appelais
maîtresse poule est ce qui a valu
quelques mots à mes parents on peut
comprendre alors évidemment alors moi je
vous dis petit je rêvais d'être black je
rêvais d'être eddie murphy c'était mon
idole gérard beverly hills 2 au cinéma
flic doit disparaître je trouvais beau
magnifique gaulle et tout ça voilà tout
est noir il passe alors je suis blanc et
ça s'est joué à ça ça s'est joué à
et du coup on sait poser une petite
question à quoi ressemble iriez-vous
c'est pas français si vous étiez du sexe
opposé oui et là on a des matches où on
a du cachet ont regardé ce que ça donne
j'ai un fou rire au bureau
monsieur mathias et marilou berry c'est
marilou berry mais non il est belge mais
c'est toi en fermage vous dites bien
mais waiting burnham et réparait ce que
tu préfères en femme parce qu'on peut
encore tout richer directrice
administrative du groupe sais pas quoi
ouais ouais mais des lunettes et c'est
considérable mais c'est bien fini la
tension n'a pas terminé laurent luna va
les faire dans l'ordre aux
directives jackie lombard à qui l'on bat
ses acquis en bas mais non non l'argent
ici c'est plus meghan markle de critères
victoria beckham en fin de vie eva
longoria eva longoria et bientôt on y va
crescendo jean michel maire
non manière à tabac et bunge dans son
ensemble et leurs revendications mais ça
fait mûr mec t'es mieux avec je vous
promets que c'est vrai ils ont fait le
coup des jeux faits nous tous des
cheveux on irène relais c'est comme ça
ils sont déjà comme ça non mais regarde
regarde certaines relèvent de toujours
mais si mal et le regard et les noms là
souffle ou un way toi touchante et
attention je crains c'est ça donne
quelque chose là là à pour garder voilà
avec la tenue
[Applaudissements]
et gallas c'est florian mais même si loi
mais non d'une flore léonce ordinateur à
patiner sur ton
kg
attention florian c'est florian passé
que tu vends à n'en pas danser mais
superman
sont mis à mal lors en effet j'ai
réfléchi j'ai fait plus facile que
l'époque de changer de sexe après leur
saisie attention le suivant est beau des
beaux des baux
diriger ses fils alors moi
j'ai créé un compte instagram à mon
alter ego masculin ouais et il vit sa
meilleure vis avec juanito mais non
cette famille en fait il
était toujours célibataire ces prêts des
comptes à g et je vous dirai c'est quoi
ces cas un compte aussi deux sur un site
de rencontre mais les célibataires par
broc je sens qu'elle péter panique non
et re série 1 coupé dans cet énoncé suis
désolé attention la misère
la différence n'est pas flagrante
là c'est la même
désolé mais
[Rires]
en fait je vous dire un truc c'est
horrible ce que je vais dire pardon en
mer et la quesada oui
j'entends que la vanne s'est un peu
calmé tout le monde non pas physiquement
physiquement vraiment
et attention tu le veuilles corrigez moi
je pense que je vais être bonne oui base
et celle ci a basé son
[Applaudissements]
show des miss a bien failli la prod il a
payé la provenance et qu'il arrive il
fait influence aux intelligente les
superbes à la seat yeux non y'a pas moi
on
dirait hélène darroze quand elle était
jeune hélène darroze coach a ajouté un
petit heures d'amélie mauresmo
examinera si comme moi
vous n'avez plus envie mais enfin quand
on est bon on est beaucoup quand on est
belle on n'est pas pressé mais c'est pas
mal quand même à 00h30 yens
et encore ce chaque samatan